Hello bitches.
Have you ever seen that Russian lady
that can pick up?
I think she can carry like 32 kilograms
for their pussy.
It might be more than that.
It's like more than 70 pounds I believe.
She can show.
I haven't checked.
Yeah.
She has this ability to like,
I guess they put like a ball and then
attach a string to a ball at the end of
the string is a weight and she puts that
ball inside of her pussy and just locks
down on that motherfucker and then can
literally lift up like 70 pounds of
weight.
It's impressive.
I've been,
I've,
I've stood,
I've stood at one end of a strip club
and had a,
the in Bangkok had a tie stripper fire
dots from the other side of the room out
of her pussy and pop a balloon that I
was holding up in my head.
Wow.
And she was,
she could fire those things with such
aim.
I don't know why I was so stupid because
I could have gotten to taking an eye
out,
but what kind of speed of his lame at
speed speed.
Like a what?
She must've been a good 10 meters,
so maybe 30 feet away from me.
Oh my God.
She's firing him across the room fast
enough to be able to pop a balloon with
accuracy,
with accuracy.
That's insane.
Now,
how's she doing this?
And she had like her elbows to the back
of her knees and she's got her like her
pussy up in the air.
No,
she was standing up.
I'm trying to picture exactly what
position she was in jail.
She was sort of kneel,
kneeling and like standing.
Kneeling.
Oh wait,
no,
sorry.
Not,
not kneeling.
Bent knees bent.
Standing Upright and with a thrust of
the hips,
boy shooting it out.
What bent knees standing up are facing
you facing me.
Wow.
That's crazy.
That doesn't even seem like this.
That's like shooting a gun in the air
when you're pointing it at the ground.
It doesn't even make any sense.
How did she do that?
She might've had a hands on the ground.
To be honest,
Joe.
I wasn't focused on her fucking
position.
I was focused on whether or not she was
going to take my,
I had my eyes closed most of the time.
Well,
she had her hands on the ground now it
makes perfect sense.
So she's like a table table sitting
upright.
Yeah.
How's she getting the air til launch
that thing?
That's what's confusing about that.
It was so many things that she was doing
like that.
They have all kinds of tricks.
They had all kinds of stuff.
They were pink.
Started that with ping pong balls,
you know,
all the classic things.
Also razorblades Oh,
it's not pleasant.
It's an amazing what people will do if
you're confronted with a town filled
with drunk tourists who have already
seen everything.
They've seen Moy Thai kickboxing fights
where 16 year old kid's a fucking
shinned each other in the head until
they go unconscious.
They've seen legalized prostitution
everywhere.
Ladyboys everywhere.
Everything is chaos.
Just fucking scooters with 37 people
piled on him.
And what do they gotta do?
They they,
they have to adapt.
What's def?
It's evolution.
It's adapt or die.
You know,
you have to adapt.
You have to figure out how to,
how to,
how to stand out.
Well,
you got to shoot a dart out of your
pussy,
honey.
That Josh sips his head.
Yeah.
There's,
I mean,
you want,
you want to make the argument that
people are,
that's,
that's like one of the best arguments.
I look at that.
That's not to mention like,
I mean,
I've been to shows there where they're
just,
I remember the finale to one show where
it was like a bear about how 25
I may do my background,
my religion.
I mean,
this shit that we have done is,
it just,
it's like everything that they're saying
that every Muslim is doing right now,
it's like,
well,
we've done that in spades and it didn't,
it wasn't a couple of extremists.
It was the leaders of the religion,
you know,
Crusades,
the inquisition,
the fucking pedophilia.
It dude,
they were in bed with the Nazis.
Yeah.
You know,
when Jews went to find like where the
hell it all,
I would have took my riding lawnmower or
whatever.
They went up at the fucking Vatican.
Like some of this shit was there now.
Oh,
oh,
is that what those,
yours,
sorry.
Yeah,
they were on both sides.
They were just like,
listen,
I don't know how this is going to shake
out.
You know a lot of people in Europe who
like that,
they've always done that.
You know there's,
there's a Dang cars the Germans make,
you know,
you've got to think they're going to
win.
I thought enough of them,
it's just too small and island are too
small a country.
It was a big country like the United
States and they made shit like that.
It'd be pretty,
one of my favorite quotes from a German
general was said,
one tiger tank was worth four American
Sherman tanks,
but the Americans always had five.
That's a great quote.
That's what it was.
It was fucking Mcdonald's.
We were just cranking them out like
fucking quarter pounders with chase and
his crazy.
When you think about the fact like Audi,
Mercedes,
BMW,
like BMW used to make jet engines and
that technology was in their tax dude.
When I was,
I mean this shit I've been reading is
like when American soldiers killed
somebody German,
they dropped the American gun and picked
up the German feeling.
Yeah.
Like are are machine guns I guess
overheated or there's,
I don't know.
You know,
come on man.
You like car nearing,
you know how it is.
I mean we've got,
we got the corvette,
we got a couple,
but most of them are kind of a Monte
Carlo.
Yeah,
we have like old muscle cars.
What I like is,
I like the old muscle cars cause the way
they look and the way they sound,
but the way they drive could be if you
took like a,
uh,
1980s porsche or a unit seven,
he's going to look in 1973 porsche like
a 1973,
nine,
11.
These the candle.
Pretty fucking good.
Pretty God damn good.
I mean,
not like a new car,
but pretty good.
The American,
what the American excuses is,
we had all this land so we could have
straight roads.
What they had over there do.
Those were like the original cow paths
when they will bring in fucking
revisions to town and then they just
paved over and basically and then all of
a sudden,
how do we go 200 miles an hour on this?
That's why you know Formula One has
right and left turns best we'll do is
just drive in a circle over here.
I love it,
dude.
I love that.
The more I travel,
the funnier we are.
Like we're fucking loud.
We got a lot of shit but were not bad.
They try to make us seem like we're bad,
but we're not.
But it's just,
we just are a product of where we're
from.
And who's kidding who,
man?
It's,
is it any more fun than just stomping on
the gas?
I called up 200 miles an hour to
straight line.
Well,
fine.
Get that Bentley 1929 Bentley.
God.
Well wait till you get towards newer
shit.
Look at that mercy.
Hold on.
Backups that Mercedes.
Look at that thing.
19 Whoa,
look at that.
It's amazing.
1930 count count.
Trossy oh,
that's the sound of the engine.
Yeah.
Oh,
you click on it,
you get the salary.
And this is why their tanks were better
than ours.
Look how pretty that are shit.
1930s.
It's like,
Oh God.
How the fuck did you get started in this
business?
You seem like a fairly normal person.
Granted I've only met you for a very
short amount of time,
but you seem completely normal.
Uh,
it's,
it's a really good story.
Um,
I was 17 years old at the time and uh,
I was traveling abroad,
I was actually exchange student in Japan
and I was really lonely.
Like I stayed with a host family and I
didn't know any Japanese and I know you
and I spoke English and so I was online
just all the time,
like you know,
on,
I mean this is kind of before my space
or facebook or anything like that,
but I'd go to different like social
networking sites and talk to people.
And um,
one day this guy starts talking to me
and he's a total pervert.
He,
he's like into a getting peed on and he
really has a thing for like panty hose
and,
and so he strikes up a conversation with
me cause he just thinks I'm very
attractive and all this and I was kind
of like grossed out by them,
but it intrigued at the same time,
you know?
And so I was like,
okay,
I'm talking to a guy online,
you can't do anything to me.
So I kept the lines of communication
open and we'd talk here and there and,
and he always tried to,
um,
convince me to meet him.
He really wanted me to piano and stuff
like that.
And I was like,
no,
not going to do that.
Am I going to do that?
I kept turning him down and then,
uh,
one day he was like,
all right,
like I get it,
you're not going to meet me,
but I just,
I think your pitch should be bottled and
sold.
It was like,
I was like,
all right by it then.
Like I didn't think he was serious.
I was like,
guy's full of shit.
But I was like,
fine by it.
And a,
and he did,
he bought a 12 ounce bottle just like
this,
um,
of my yearn for $250.
And after that I specify the ounces than
it had to been.
Uh,
I don't think so.
No,
I think we were just a bottle.
That's what we said.
Just a bottle.
Yeah.
Right.
And um,
yeah,
from there I was like,
oh,
there has to be more guys like this.
Like this guy found me on accident.
Like this is just a mistake.
Like what,
what happened if I went looking for guys
like this,
I'll give you promoted it.
Yeah.
Or like kind of sought it out.
And uh,
so I was like,
okay,
I've heard of like women selling their
use panties before.
I know that's a thing.
Um,
and so I started searching to see if
there was like a website that like I
could be on or something that catered to
that.
And a,
and I did,
I found this auction that's just like
Ebay,
but it specializes and like use panties
or socks or panty hose or anything like
a woman can wear,
can auction on the site.
And a,
so I was like,
oh,
this,
yeah,
this is,
uh,
I'm doing this,
and I just started selling all sorts of
stuff.
[inaudible].